This is the Ghazipur landfill
in Delhi, India.
It’s almost 20 stories high
and it often collapses,
killing the waste pickers that work there.
Last year, when temperatures
hit 43 degrees Celsius,
it caught fire three times in a month
and burned for 48 hours straight,
exposing the city
to harmful particulate matter.
This happens because the organic
waste in the landfills
decomposes to form methane,
a highly flammable
and potent greenhouse gas.
And as we have more and more heat waves,
the problem will only get worse.
This landfill in Buenos Aires
causes the pollution
equivalent to roughly 1.4 million cars,
or the same as roughly two
average-sized coal-fired power plants.
Landfills like these are major
contributors to climate change
because of the methane they emit.
Methane ...
comes from everywhere in the world,
but in developing countries,
emissions are expected to double by 2050.
Methane is therefore
the Global South's climate challenge,
because it's a development challenge.
As poor countries get richer,
their demand for food
and consumer goods will increase,
and so will the waste they generate.
If we're going to keep warming
under 1.5 degrees Celsius,
we need to reduce methane
emissions in half by 2050.
But we must do so
without getting in the way
of quality-of-life improvements
in the Global South.
That's why, in 2022, I became the CEO
of the Global Methane Hub,
a major philanthropic effort
focused on methane mitigation,
based out of Santiago, Chile.
Methane doesn't get the same attention
as carbon dioxide does,
but it's contributed
to nearly half the warming
we've experienced to date.
It's short-lived,
so we stop emissions now,
its warming effect will soon follow.
If we only focus
on carbon-dioxide emissions,
we're only going to get
half the temperature reduction
with these next two decades.
Mitigating methane, therefore,
is the fastest, most efficient way
to reduce temperature
within our lifetime.
But don't get me wrong,
this is not about delaying action
on fossil fuels.
40 percent of methane emissions
come from fossil-fuel extraction.
But today, I'm going to talk
about the other 60 percent
that not a lot of people talk about,
which is food systems’ emissions --
food production and food waste.
I’m a biochemical engineer, a professor
and I was formerly
the environmental minister for Chile.
Before I got into politics,
when I was a graduate student
at the University of Iowa,
I’d work with NASA,
tracking air pollution across continents
using aircraft and satellites.
When I got back home,
I used the same tools to develop
air-quality forecasting systems
that helped change the way we did things.
And we had a radical drop
in air-pollution levels.
But during my tenure,
a large landfill caught fire,
and it put the whole city of Santiago
under a black cloud
of carcinogenic soot.
It was an event
our model couldn't predict.
It was methane, again.
Another landfill nearby
smelled so terrible
that neighbors protested for weeks.
And they were right --
nobody deserves to live like that.
And we could do something about it.
The organic waste in landfills
is one of the most visible
sources of methane,
literally.
And food systems,
food loss and waste,
is a big part of the problem.
Fifty percent of all
food systems’ emissions
come from food that nobody ever eats.
In Sub-Saharan Africa,
37 percent of all food that's produced
is either lost or wasted,
either because there's not enough
infrastructure to store it,
to transport it,
or to keep it from spoiling.
The other part ends up in the trash,
and when that organic waste
is concentrated in the landfill,
we can see the methane
this waste emits from space.
The NGO Carbon Mapper
is a public-private partnership
that's leveraging technology
developed by NASA scientists
to pinpoint methane sources
across the world.
They started with aircraft
and soon they’ll be up in a satellite.
Seeing methane this way
contributes to real mitigation,
and the Sunshine Canyon Landfill
in Los Angeles
is an example of this.
Airborne methane data
inform basic operational improvements,
such as covering
the daily trash with liners,
which led to a radical drop in emissions,
60 percent lower emissions,
and the complaints
from neighbors disappeared.
Now we decided
to take this effort globally,
and with our colleagues from RMI,
the Clean Air Task Force
and Carbon Mapper,
we put together the Waste MAP,
the Waste Methane Assessment Platform,
which links satellite information,
NGOs and local governments
to intervene.
With other colleagues,
we’re working in the biggest
landfills in the world,
including the one you saw in Delhi,
the one in Buenos Aires,
and of course the city
of Santiago, where I live.
Pinpointing methane sources
allows us to stop existing emissions,
but it also helps prevent
new emissions from occurring, too.
And it starts with organic
waste diversion.
We could do a lot of different solutions,
like composting.
We could do food banking,
or we could turn
that organic waste into food,
like what my dog, Rucio, eats,
made from soldier flies
that grew on food waste.
Now don't worry,
I would never feed my dog
anything I wouldn't eat.
(Laughter)
But food waste is not the only problem.
What we eat also has big impact.
And in that, cows --
raising cows for dairy and meat
is the single largest
anthropogenic source of methane.
That's right, cow burps.
The scientific name for that
is enteric fermentation.
If you feed an animal low-quality food
instead of high-quality food,
a lot of that energy
doesn't go to create milk,
it goes to digestion and cow burps.
So an animal in Sub-Saharan Africa
causes five times more emissions
than one in North America,
per unit of milk,
becasue it's usually eating
suboptimal food.
So improved breeding,
feeding and animal welfare
could reduce emissions
and improve income for farmers.
But we have to do a lot more
about cow-burp emissions,
and that's why we're launching
the Enteric Fermentation
Research and Development Accelerator,
a 200-million-dollar effort
that will focus on reducing
livestock emissions,
and it will be the biggest
effort of its kind.
You may have heard some scientists
are feeding algae or seaweed to animals
to change their metabolism
to reduce methane emissions,
and there's a whole bunch
of solutions like that,
but for each one, we have to know:
Is it safe? Does it last?
And how will it perform
when it’s not in optimal settings,
like when the animal
is out in pasture all day,
instead of being fed?
We hope that this research initiative
will deliver the scientific
breakthroughs we need
to reduce livestock emissions
and keep 1.5 alive.
When I was minister,
I would often hear from my colleagues,
"Why should we act on climate change,
if it was the rich countries
that caused the problem?"
And it's partly true.
Emissions have historically come
from developed countries,
but they're rising fast
in the developing world.
We don't need to follow a path
we know will lead
to higher emissions and pollution --
we could cut straight across
into sustainable solutions.
But what I hear from colleagues
was based on the premise
that reducing emissions
will make our day-to-day lives worse
because of all the things
we'd have to do without.
But this is a false narrative,
and it's not the case for methane.
Methane is a global problem,
but the benefits are felt
where action is taken.
Vulnerable communities
that aren't exposed
to the constant threat of dump fires
or foul smells.
Landfills that aren't filled
with rotting organic waste
that could instead be turned
to food or fertilizer.
Farmers that are already
under the threat of climate change
could gain income and resilience
because of better, more efficient
livestock and rice production.
You and I ...
can't do much to create
zero-emission cement
or change grids
across countries or continents --
well, some of you can, but not everybody.
(Laughter)
But 60 percent
of our emissions from methane
come from our food, our trash
and our neighborhoods.
And taking action on reducing methane now
is a big step to saving the planet.
And we could start when we get back home,
composting our food.
We'll see the benefits --
better living conditions, cleaner air,
improved food security,
right here and right now.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)